he's Roy Firestone he's got a book out
another book it's called that's what I'm
talking about available online or
wherever books are sold and Amazon too
and Amazon too so let me get the full
background introduction here I used to
work at CNN and I believe at 5:30 every
day on ESPN up close would come on right
and it didn't matter who Roy was
interviewing I I watched and listened
because I wanted to see how we got from
point A to point B and so I learned how
to be a better interviewer by watching
you on up close and it's your questions
were brief you got to the point and
people always say Oh Roy makes people
cry and I went really didn't make that
many people cry but he did elicit
responses that you wouldn't get anyplace
else right people weren't trying to hone
their craft at interviewing athletes and
you would bring somebody in even if I
wasn't interested I was interested after
you were done interviewing them I
appreciate that Dan but first of all we
actually put a clock on a number on 25
people cried it out of 5,000 shows but
the ones that people remember are the
show is where people cried and when
Rodman cried that's when Cameron Crowe
called us and they wanted to do the
scene from Jerry Maguire originally
Rodman was gonna be Rod Tidwell people
don't know that
wait Rodman was gonna play that role he
turned that down the role he was gonna
play rod Tidwell so Cuba Gooding so
Kubek so I can I gotta take a quick
story so we get to the show they get to
the movie we're in the Sony Studios I
meet Tom Cruise and he's a big sports
fan stock car racing big great she you
got to go to see Cuba I said well I live
from Miami I live near Cuba he goes no
no Cuba now Cuba Gooding was not a star
at this point yeah so he he says Cuba
and I went were in Cuba are you from I
mean literally that kind of nonsense and
he goes no no that's my name we do a
scene we didn't even roll we didn't even
rehearse we dad lived the scene and the
first take when he gets the contract
you're not gonna make me cry Roy he
grabs me and I'm on a roller and my
chair is rolling off this height seat
that this heightened said I started fall
back on my head I'm not kidding you and
they the grips grabbed me that was
second the first take the second takes
the one you see flash-forward six months
later I'm in Liverpool England and I'm
at a reception for at the heart at the
cafe cavern club and I get a tap on my
shoulder swear this is true I think I
know you is Paul McCartney I think I
think I think I've met you before and I
said I don't know things know where have
I seen you and I said Paul this is a
thrill but I have no idea what you're
talking about and the woman with him
goes to the movie the movie he goes oh
you mean Jerry Maguire he goes that's it
Maguire and then he goes he goes what's
your name and I said boy goes you're not
gonna make me cry you talk about a
thrill that was a thrill absolutely who
did you not get to interview like the
way Bruce I think would probably okay
but but is there one that while you were
doing the show that you couldn't get you
know mostly you know we had them all
pretty much I had someone ask me of
Tiger Woods he doesn't do a lot of sit
down one-on-ones I'd him at 11 years old
I had Shaq at 16 years old and of course
throughout their career yeah I remember
when I I had Shaq went throughout his
career
you know Shaq grew into a personality at
first he was deeply shy and introverted
oh yeah he comes off the plane if they
win the Olympics you earth probably in
Athens and maybe you would cover it with
NBC I said Shaq you went to Athens you
win the gold medal while you were in
happens did you have a chance to visit
the Parthenon he goes Roy we went to a
lot of clubs I can't remain you ever get
this do you ever get this would you have
to interview a guy after they lose
that's the worst crap well Buckner oh
you did yes yes oh they said the Lakers
losing five to this Pistons and I got to
go to the locker room in Detroit a
Palace of Auburn Hills at two o'clock in
the morning Shaq's the last one there
the check ESPN wants me to ask you about
your emotional state after losing the
world championship right I'm a little
pissed off okay so here's why here's my
follow up brilliant follow-up question
how pissed off are you
and he actually goes the highest level
of acidity really and I said what time
he and Kobe you can get along so I said
Shaq you and Kobe are different
personalities how would you define if he
goes well Kobe is a loner and me I like
to think of myself as a socialist like
Karl Marx is brave right now but you
know you know what it's like Danny to do
this to do this thing for so many years
it's an adventure it's really a journey
it really is and you know the key to
interviewing and we've talked about this
before I think is just being curious
well yeah like just I I have to really
want to know what you have mm-hmm and
you know I always appreciated that your
question got to the point brevity is so
important in the question yep because I
don't care about my question people go
all you got great questions I go how are
the answers the answers are all that
matters man yes because then your
questions are better by the answers you
get and the other thing then is when you
get people come to play you know what
that means people who really want to do
your show I was the one guy that you
just said
this is served on a platter here for me
Charles Barkley are you how many times
have you had Charles my name is this is
a this is a natural I one time had I
don't have a picture of this they may
put it in I interviewed allows you one
in Berkeley together because I wanted to
show how two different completely
different cultures can come back
together and I said gentlemen I said
hakim Charles
here's an offbeat question do you
believe you're gonna go to heaven so
Elisha one well I believe if my service
to God is pure and consistent and comes
from the spirit of giving for all
mankind yes I believe I will go to
heaven I said very nicely Sarah came I
saw but how about you Charles he goes I
don't know but it's definitely gonna be
a close vote do you know what I'm
talking about where you get the you get
gold friezes treasure gold and he and
you know what else he doesn't he's
comfortable in his own skin
I don't think Jordan is is comfortable
in his skin as Berkeley isn't his who's
the current athlete you want to sit down
with
I think LeBron you know III did
something brief with him but I really
what do you what do you think you're not
you don't know yet from him I don't you
know he's I'm sure he's talked about the
poverty have you hear stories of poverty
I mean this guy was eating ketchup
sandwiches you know and mother was in
jail and the hardship and how he still
Lee Jenkins did a great piece and Sports
Illustrated about how he goes home after
a game sometimes drives all the way back
to was it is it Akron Akron Akron and he
just drives by with his wife sometimes
two o'clock in the morning to see where
he came from you don't hear that much in
today's athlete I still think he's an
interesting guy and he's also evolved to
I think he would be one now Roy had
Jimmy Stewart oh I knew you were gonna
pull this this is you do a great Jimmy
kept but Roy has this legendary actor on
oh and I'm watching this and I'm just
curious like what is Roy gonna ask the
legendary Jimmy Stewart and I don't know
how you got to that point but then
you're maybe you're asked you know
people who imitate him and then he goes
you know who does a great imitation of
you damn it Jimmy Stewart just goes I
also why one time dude it's on YouTube I
did a piece about what if he went back
to Bedford Falls today I went down the
block to the five-and-dime store and I
noticed they don't have him you know it
would be like that but he goes back to
Bedford Falls and nothing is thorny you
know I saw my girlfriend Mary people in
this audience will even know who Jimmy's
well they know from It's a Wonderful
Life you start you start this way all of
a sudden it's a wonderful life was
filmed on the block I live right now in
Encino swear I couldn't make that yep a
scene a major scene that when they walk
through the village yeah that was shot
on my block incredible in the 40s the
book is that's what I'm talking about
available
online wherever books are sold now
fritzy takes a lot of credit for your
success he was an executive producer
producer I was a researcher my first job
ever at ESPN was working with Roy as a
research and I graduated to booking
guests at some weight with all due
respect what was your name again
saad fritz I do not recall a Tod Fritz
working with me at any point it was like
25 26 I'm sorry I don't I don't recall
that hurts I will say one thing I had
never heard my voice ever my name ever
mentioned on TV but I tracked down some
old Jerome Bettis High School footage
and we had better some studio and Roy
was all excited we found this old high
school clip that they were trying to
sell him to note a game in different
schools he's played and he gave me
on-air credit that's right and said my
name that though she was a legend he was
an absolutely why don't you do that
stuff on our show Todd required
who got who was bothered by your
impersonation of them this is a good
segue for me because I want to say
something about Keith Jackson this was
the the inner the impression that got me
so to call national attention was
Letterman Letterman had me on and he
wanted you to just do Keith Jackson now
I had heard I don't know if we have the
sound effect when we have this sound
effect behind me if I asked for it of
Keith Jackson here it is let me do it
for you
[Music]
well hello get him out of this Jackson
mrs. cut its football mm and that 10 and
hold a we've got a real barnburner for
you yes indeed it did it live it'll be
ABC's Wide World of Sports with the
proctologist from Johns Hopkins
University taking on the big red suicide
machine from Jack Kevorkian junior
college roll bar there's gonna be a
whole lot of head crack let's picked up
the accent right here right now at ABC
he rolls on the right side he's got some
run room the 35 2/3 of the 25 he could
go all the way but he's hit and cracked
and fumble
and that's the way he sounded right now
Letterman hears this I do it on national
TV and I hear that Keith is pissed yes
but he wasn't really pissed he wasn't
sure what my attitude was towards what
he did tell me he goes I never said I
never said whoa never yeah but here's
here's a beautiful thing we became
really close friends at the end and he
will you do Keith Jackson for him when
he passed when he passes when he passes
Tory an his longtime wife I think there
were 65 years married or maybe almost 70
years married 60 something years she
said would you do Keith at the memorial
and I and I did I did a memorial Keith
Jan and it just gave everybody a laugh
and it was warm but Keith used to say
yeah sure Roy I never I never said whoa
Nellie but I do like the way that he
does Kiki that's true true story
did Cosell ever respond to you doing
Cosell Oh many times
we I had a be okay with it no he wasn't
okay with anything he was like right I
had can we get that hip-hop thing up up
with Mike before I do this this is I
wanted to do Howard Cosell and Muhammad
Ali as hip I need a little more sounded
the head sound headphones okay here is
Howard Cosell in Muhammad Ali a little
more wake up here we go hello everybody
I'm Howard Cosell without further ado
that's the opening bell we're here today
to fuen observe a three-time champ for
the hell of a nerve he fought all comers
with speed and savvy though in later
years he got kind of flabby ladies and
gentle Muhammad Ali now Howard Cosell I
hear what you say you fill a hot air you
got a bad toupee I bought with style I
fall with class you ain't nothing but a
pain in my ass but Cosell just to say
that in the 1981 World Series Dodgers
Yankees I go in the dugout and I do this
that my friend was not an authentic
impersonation now if you do Keith
Jackson that's quite a different thing
he liked it when you would Lampoon to
others but not himself I know there were
a couple of times that you had some
guests who probably wanted to take a
swing I'm ever Boris Barry Switzer very
good not a problem with you yes I talked
about white trash
I don't even how I got into this because
this was about how he grew up as a
bootlegger but why did you use the
expression right I don't know damn of an
idiot
that's why I just said you know people
would say that you grew up in a period
where your family in trailer park white
trash and he goes what do you mean by
what trash and I'm he's kidding I'll
punch you right in the mouth and I went
whoa this was do you ever get any
physical moments where people are rude
and or they think you're rude or a rod a
rod and Lawrence Taylor really yeah well
I had Ted Turner on one time and it was
the day he was debuting his 24-hour
music channel and they didn't tell me
that they were pulling the plug that day
and I said and he comes on the show the
theme is rolling those are close sports
look but Ted Turner right I said Ted you
tell us about this 24-hour me hears
you're trying to make you're trying to
embarrass me all right what I didn't
even know that they pulled the plug in
that moment he gets up and he leaves
Kevin Johnson got up and left pulled his
mic but you know we were lucky because
we were taping yeah but in some cases
the bird was waiting and we didn't
meaning the satellite we didn't have a
backup guess so it was like live anyway
Tom Watson one time got angry at me for
asking about it a previous mayor knows
Ben Crenshaw I should say Ben Crenshaw
he says you know you talk to me about
anything you want oh right they just
said well you know there was some
hardship in the tough divorce and then
he says I want that show pulled for ice
it's already it's already airing and he
got mad at me I'll never talk to you
even had that kind of stuff you know but
- but - steak you know curious I loved
it I loved it you know I mean but it's
only a it's a half hour show like I my
challenge is this is three hours and the
energy level for three hours yeah is
exhausting like I look for the little
breaks there and you know when you do it
and then how much how much did you go as
scripted when you were interviewing
people never I never had a script never
I have I would have a word
you know father suicide or whatever
we were talking about or you know mother
drug addict there whatever was to remind
myself that was the scenario but I
remember had Shannon sharp on you ever
have Shannon I know he's at Fox now but
Todd does a good Shannon Sharpe in
person let me here Todd I think the
Denver Bronco got to get in good I said
ladies and gentlemen I said I said
Shannon based on your academic he was a
very self-effacing guy is it based on
your academic career would you say you
graduated to the level of magna [ __ ]
laude this is Roy de facto I graduated
is thank you Laurie
[Laughter]
you can't you can't right now your dad
know you can and Jimmy V was came to
play Jimmy V was Wilt Chamberlain I
gotta give me a quick well okay 30
second okay so I come out of a
restaurant ever met him before
79 he's got a white Rolls Royce
convertible two dogs Great Dane
Dalmatians his biggest horses beautiful
blonde because at the time and this is
before the meat too
he says you know I was the all-time
leading scorer okay wilt okay will yeah
so I go to and I had never met Whoopi
but he's wearing his silver and purple
jumped silver and purple silk jumps it
with a burgundy beret he's got a
lemon-lime feather I'll never forget
this African orange a wraparound
sunglasses working stick no shoes backed
up against the steering wheel
I said Wilt Chamberlain you're seven to
your $325 look at this getup you have
here would you like to come on do the
show this is Roy I'd like to come do the
show but right now I'm trying to keep a
low profile right it you can't write it
the book is that's what I'm talking
about he's Roy Firestone if well if you
love what you've heard here you'll love
the book and they can get on Roy
Firestone calm and one last if I'm gonna
throw one more plug I do performance
shows I do Ola I do shows all over the
country just did Baltimore Brooks
Robinson by the way said tell Dan that I
yeah he shouldn't hate me because I
played well against the red my Reds I
told him that
yeah I said man you ruined my childhood
books but Brooks was in my audience
Saturday night we did a show at the
Caesars and I just shows all over the
country and I loved interviewing still
but give us that website again Roy
Firestone calm and just plug books and
we decide them for you and I just love
doing this it's great to see you Dan I'm
so happy for you and all the great
things that have happened Thank You Roy
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]